I've never heard of a moment in which a
filmmaker was making a factual film
where something actually happened in
real life that could benefit their
movies so much I mean can you imagine
having that just drop in your life if
you were Kathryn Bigelow I mean your
entire movie just got a thousand times
better zero dark thirty is being
marketed as the factual tale of the
manhunt for Osama bin Laden now as I
mentioned my intro during the making of
this movie Osama bin Laden had not yet
been killed and I don't even know what
they were going to do with this movie
but he was found and killed during the
making of this film and that gave these
filmmakers an opportunity to take their
film in a completely different direction
and unless none of you have watched the
news for like the past year I'm
definitely not spoiling anything and
saying that it's like saying the Titanic
sinks at the end of the movie I spoiled
Jessica Chastain's character is
searching relentlessly for Osama bin
Laden and any connections that he may
have and you see throughout this
two-hour and 45 or so minute film all
the different things that these people
go through to try to capture this man
and it's told in a very straightforward
factual manner in which a lot of people
are sifting facts you know the first two
hours of this movie nothing really
happens per se I mean it's a lot of
searching and sifting and looking and
it's directed by Kathryn Bigelow who
made like Point Break and The Hurt
Locker you know some really good movies
she won an Oscar as the first female
director ever to win an Oscar a very
impressive feat there and he or she has
this movie and this is where you kind of
really could screw up because okay
you're coming off an Oscar what you're
gonna do you're gonna choose like
another war type film you're gonna make
it really gritty you're gonna make it
all handheld and it's this story that a
lot of people are going to scrutinize
and how factual is this does she succeed
I think she does this is a really good
movie and when I say that for me it
wasn't one of those movies where I just
like relish every minute of this movie
where it's like oh my god this is such
an impressive movie I just thought it
was a really well-done film and an
interesting thriller and the kind of
movie that even though I know because
I've done research about this movie I
know not everything about this movie is
factual I know certain people have come
forward and I've said yes it's exactly
happened this way I know that
really happen that way you know it's a
movie it's a Hollywood movie but I
really respect the director and the
writer for doing their best to tell a
tale as factual as they possibly could
and I don't really want to set you up
for anything or make you like expect a
certain thing out of this movie but I
can say that certain moments in this
movie are very nail-biting very
suspenseful but there are moments where
you know it's just a lot of talking and
you might be bored by that and I got to
be honest with you guys that could bore
some people because everything I've
heard from reviews before seeing this
movie was oh my god the last 40 minutes
are so amazing no one really talks about
the first two hours because the first
two hours is a lot of information
sifting interrogating and searching it's
a lot of characters looking through
documents and talking about
possibilities and not saying that's a
bad thing at all I'm just saying that
don't go into this movie expecting it to
be like a slam-bang action thriller it's
not the last like 40 minutes or so yes
you get more of that there but this is
just a really tense film with great
performances particularly by Jessica
Chastain well you watch these people try
to figure out where this guy is and it's
not Hollywood eyes it's not even as
Hollywood eyes as The Hurt Locker was
it's very straightforward but I guess my
main problem with the movie and really
my only problem with the film and this
will not be a problem for everyone some
people will think wow that that wasn't a
problem for me at all I really enjoyed
it I didn't really get a sense of
character I didn't really feel like the
people in this movie were characters
because you never learn a thing about
them ever you don't know a thing about
Jessica Chastain's character you just
there she is and she's doing her work
and I get it you know you're supposed to
be so focused in the moment but it would
have been nice to get more of a feel of
her as a person so I could care more
about her with some of the more intense
moments in the film were happening and
it's the same for all the characters in
this movie I never really latched on to
anyone so there wasn't as much suspense
as there could have been towards the
final moments but I still really enjoyed
zero dark thirty and I think that if you
haven't seen it it's coming out soon
it's definitely been in limited release
for a while and people have been talking
about it zero dark thirty is a tense
well acted well directed thriller that
should definitely be experienced and it
has such a suspenseful finale that there
were certain moments where I was getting
goosebumps and shivers like oh my god
like I really want to know is that how
it went down I'm gonna give zero dark
thirty a B+ it's definitely a very good
movie there were just a few elements of
it I thought could have been a little
bit better in the character Department
nevertheless good film check it out
thanks a lot for watching guys and
always would be like this video then you
can click right here and get stuck man
eyes
[Music]